so during this
[Applause]
dear colleagues good morning
today we have the pleasure of welcoming
Nicos risto the leades the President of
Cyprus in Strasbourg thank you dear
Nicos for being here with us today as
part of our this is Europe series of
debates to discuss our common agenda for
Europe's future
it is testimony to your commitment as
president and to cyprus's commitment to
Europe as the European Union continues
to face unprecedented challenges on
multiple fronts
Cyprus will play an important and
strategic role in Europe's Energy
Solution in ensuring that the
Mediterranean remains a sea of peace and
prosperity and in pushing Europe forward
in showing that it is the size of ideas
that matters more than geography
together I know that we can find
solutions to intergenerational questions
there is room to build trust cyprus's
solidarity with turkey after the
earthquakes of last February was proof
of that and the anikos let me be clear
you will not be left alone your
challenges are Europe's too this is not
just a Cyprus question but a Europe
question
the first thing that I said
in this house when I was entrusted to
lead it was to tell Cyprus that you are
not alone
that Europe will never be complete as
long as Cyprus remains divided that we
can use the power of Europe to find
Solutions and ways forward and this is
why this European Parliament will
continue to support our shared ambition
to see the reunification of your Island
under the hospices of the Un Peace plan
if Cyprus has taught Europe anything
throughout history it is that the future
is full of possibility and we all look
forward to building a European future
together with Cyprus dear president
sternikos the floor is yours
[Applause]
honorable president of the European
Parliament
honorable members of the in Parliament
vice president of the European
Commission
first of all I would like to thank the
president for her kind invitation asking
me to come here a little bit over three
months after I became president of the
Republic of Cyprus
to address the European Parliament to
speak before all of you and outline my
vision of the present and the future of
the European Union
the present and the future of our
European citizens
and to explain how I think that together
we can tackle common challenges
and I believe that on a consensual basis
we can contribute to a brighter future
for the European Union this is a
symbolic chamber the plenary Chamber of
the European Parliament here in
Strasbourg and I'm quite familiar with
it and maybe it's because I've worked
with the European Parliament in the past
that I feel such strong emotions
but above all I feel a sense of
responsibility
responsibility because now I stand here
before you
as the president of a member state I'm a
member now of the European Council
for me it is a huge honor to address you
today you are the elected
representatives of European citizens and
I address you here today in a chamber
where the constant and strong heartbeat
of European democracy beats it is a
great honor and of course we also owe
you very much because I know that you
play a decisive role you contribute to
high quality of life of our citizens in
all corners of Europe and you're also
working towards a brighter future based
on Prosperity
and security and this is for the whole
planet
ladies and gentlemen
I am one of those who believe that the
European Union is the most important
Collective achievement of our continent
since the Period of Enlightenment
the political vision of Enlighten of
these enlightened individuals to bring
together our continent through setting
up the institutions of the European
Union in order to secure peace and in
order to make sure that there would be
peace and prosperity for our peoples and
I believe that this is a
more necessary than ever at the same
time I think that the work done by these
pioneers
hasn't been completed I think it is
constantly developing and evolving and
now it is up to us to decide how this is
going to move forward
the project that we have inherited
should be seen as a legacy and it should
be seen as an achievement that we have
to bolster
and in order to do this we need to be
bold we need to be Visionaries and we
have to be decisive
it is not a choice it is our duty to
strive hard for in a European Union that
will become a stronger every day through
the deepening of our institutions
through more common policies and with
yes the member states giving up more of
their National sovereignty in order to
contribute to these common supranational
institutions so that we everyone can
have a good life and live in peace
security
and in order to improve the future for
All European citizens regardless of
where they come from and where they live
ladies and gentlemen
I truly believe that the European Union
is the biggest model of peace
and security after a dreadful 20th
century that claimed the lives of
millions of people on our continent
I'm fully aware as a current European
leader that we have a duty that we have
a duty to develop this model of peace
that Schumann Monet Altera Spinelli
Poland respark and sumon vey bequestas
I am a staunch proponent of a targeted
approach of taking this step by step in
order to build a European Union that has
clearly
Federal features
this is what our Collective interests
demand of us because the current
situation is difficult it is constantly
evolving and changing there are multiple
challenges on the international stage
and that is why we have to make sure
that we join forces and work effectively
and as EU members States we shouldn't
only think about how we're going to
survive on the international stage given
the strong geopolitical rivalries
as EU member states we have to create
the necessary conditions to make sure
that we are at the Forefront that we are
united in diversity and that we harness
our strong human potential
uh sharing our common values and
principles that anchor the European
project so strongly
I firmly believe that we can make the
European Union a Trailblazer and a
protagonist on the international stage
after the tragedy of the disastrous
Wars of the first half of the 20th
century and with the aim of never going
through this again there were those who
were bold and courageous enough to have
a vision and a dream for a United Europe
they realize and rightly so that we can
draw strength from our diversity they
realized that power and strength comes
from Unity
so we have to build on this Legacy and
we have to strengthen our Unity so that
it cannot be swayed by anyone this will
be our main tool our strength our
compass for the future that we want for
Europe and our citizens
so we harness this unity and I'm very
proud of this and this is what we drew
on in order to tackle the multiple
challenges that are testing us that have
tested us that are still testing us to
this very day ladies and gentlemen
Cyprus in the most southern Eastern tip
of the European Union
has been an extricable part of Europe
from the beginning of time
we have political economic and cultural
ties and all of these ties were set up
thousands of years ago and we've
constantly nurtured these ties
Cyprus joined the EU in the spring of
2004 on a historic day that I still
remember it is alive in our memories and
the memories of all cypriots this is
something that we had been waiting for
for a very long time it was something
natural it was a return to where we
belonged by
making the existing strong historic ties
with Continental Europe
reality again
I believe that when we joined the EU in
2004 we could say that this moment was
the most important historic moment since
the Republic of Cyprus was set up back
in 1960 and it also symbolizes the
return to our home our common European
home
ladies and gentlemen today almost after
20 years the Cyprus is an active member
of the European Union
and it's against this backdrop
that will be proud to take on the
rotating presidency of Cyprus during my
term this will be in the first half of
2026. I was lucky enough to be actively
involved in the first presidency of the
Republic of Cyprus and I have no doubt
about the fact that the upcoming
presidency will be an important
Milestone not only for the European
Union but also for my country I'd like
to assure you that today that Cyprus
will make the most of this opportunity
in order to offer a positive
contribution and as an honest broker to
make sure that we have institutional
unity and in order to make sure that we
can go through as many legislative files
as possible in order to increase the
added value of the EU legislative
process and so that EU citizens can
benefit from this moreover we're already
examining necessary very political
initiatives that I would like us to take
during the recipient presidency
this is about political cooperation with
the Mediterranean and the Middle East
honorable members of the European
Parliament
I was a recently elected as president of
the Republic of Cyprus but this wouldn't
have been possible without the support
of the two main parties but also with
the decisive support of civil society
and smaller parties and movements and
all this was done on the basis of a
Manifesto focusing on human beings this
is vital
uh we'll also be looking at Best
Practices in other member states this
model is backed by what we have been
taught by our active involvement in the
European Union for all these years my
aim is to make sure that super citizens
live a good life and that there's peace
and security I was elected and I believe
that this confirms the need for Change
and because people want citizens
problems to be heard so that we can come
up with Solutions and so that Cyprus and
cypriot citizens can look at their daily
lives with optimism and they can look
towards the future and the basis of
equality for all citizens cooperation in
the fields of education and health we
want a smooth transition towards a
Greener more digital modern and equal
and fair Society I've listened to our
society and right after I was elected I
started implementing a program which is
my social contract with the cypriot
people
we have the upcoming European elections
in order to elect the new members of the
European Parliament this is on the
horizon it's just around the corner and
I believe that it is our duty to listen
to Citizens we have to bring them closer
to the European project or even better
we need to convince them that we are
their voice that we are not an ivory
tower that we are we stand by their side
and that we have an overarching common
goal which is prosperity and we want to
make sure that everyone's rights are
respected we believe in equal
opportunities for all we have to regain
the trust of our citizens and make sure
that they believe in the European ideals
of Peace Corporation
solidarity and prosperity now if we are
to achieve this we have to do more to
make sure that European citizens are
aware of what the EU does for them and
how they contribute to
security their security and daily lives
so we need to communicate better we need
our citizens to truly feel the changes
that we are achieving with uh such
effort the green transition the digital
transformation and digital transition
migration and so on it is our duty to
show political responsibility and we
need to ensure that the proposals that
the citizens themselves put forward are
followed on it was here in this very
chamber where we heard from the citizens
so this has to be the guiding principle
in our compass for the next steps that
we take in the future
I also firmly believe that the European
Union has to be has to have strategic
autonomy when it comes to security
energy health and other areas
this doesn't mean that the EU is going
to isolate itself or that we're going to
turn our backs on our natural or
historic allies quite to the country
but I believe that today and more than
ever we need a European Union that will
be in a position to tackle challenges
and in this way it will be more valuable
but it also be an ally for its friends
and be on an equal footing strategic
autonomy is absolutely necessary in
light of our interests in this
constantly evolving International
reality
the Russian invasion of Ukraine which
must be condemned reminds us of this
Russian invasion of Ukraine the world
continues it is therefore crucial that
we equally continue our support to the
heroic people of Ukraine
let me be clear dear friends will never
allow booster changes stemming from
violence and War we will never accept
the result of Russia's aggression
against an independent sovereign state
it is a matter of principle and a
priority to ensure that anarchy and the
love of the Jungle will not Prevail over
international law and the international
rule based oyster
the European Union ought to be at the
Forefront of a cult in international law
and the U.N Charter this is after all an
inherent part of its foundation and of
the European Union treaties
for sea periods in particular who
themselves have been victims of foreign
Invasion and almost half a century long
occupation by turkey there is no other
choice
from day one of Russia's operation
against Ukraine Cyprus has maintained an
unequivocal principle stance in support
of the independence sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine this is
the path of which we will continue
Cyprus will continue to support Ukraine
including through the European peace
facility and the European Union
monitoring monitoring assistance mission
who have been sending to Crane the
biggest humanitarian Aid package ever
assembled on the island we are also
hosting a large number of Ukrainian
refugees relative to our population and
we will continue to do so
Cyprus will be their safe haven for as
long as necessary
within the European Union we exhibited
unprecedented unity in response to this
war
our Unity proved to be our most
important tool we have taken painful
decisions that have come at a cost for
our people peoples and societies but it
is a cost worth Sheltering
in unity we need to continue to jointly
address issues that affect Ukraine but
also have repercussions Beyond European
Union borders it has become blatantly
and painfully clear that peace run in
the European continent cannot be taken
for granted that we must defend it and
that a threat to peace somewhere in
Europe is a threat to which in every
country in Europe
Russia's military aggression against
Ukraine has also appended energy markets
triggering price volatility and energy
security across the world
a crucial a crucial new element in the
European policy response to this
situation is that a power EU Plan
Building on the full implementation of
the European green deal
as a result both the European Union and
its member states are dynamically
reshaping their energy strategies to
reflect new geopolitical realities and
to address the need for affordable
energy
this includes intensified actions to
increase gas supplies from the European
Union's trusted partners
Cyprus the only member state in the
Eastern Mediterranean region would
confirm gas reserves and with
historically excellent relations and
long-standing Partnerships in the field
of energy with the vast majority of its
neighbors can play a key role in our
joint efforts to address identity crisis
by providing a reliable Alternative
Energy Corridor to Europe comprising
diverse sources and routes
where of the view that the presence of
major oil and gas companies in the
region could be leveraged to create
synergies towards a sustainable Regional
gas market that could Supply the
European Union with gas in the immediate
future and with the with hydrogen in a
few years time
for this reason we are intensifying our
discussions with all major oil and gas
companies to implement our vision to
connect these different gas fields in
the region we have pipelines to a
modular liquefactions plant situated in
Cyprus through which gas can be exported
to Europe
in addition this region has recently
become much more proactive in pursuing
and enhancing its energy goals towards a
green transition
both Israel and Egypt are progressing
with important renewable energy projects
to export to export renewable energy as
well as to use it internally as such in
five to ten years time the regional
electricity interconnections currently
in the pipeline could contribute
significantly to the supply supply of
renewable energy from the East mid
region to the European markets
maintaining a stable and secure
environment in the Eastern Mediterranean
is to the benefit of the region and its
people but also of strategic importance
for the European Union
it is therefore critical importance of
it is therefore of critical importance
for the union to continue sending clear
and fair messages of deterrence to
potential spoilers in the region
urging them not to proceed to new
provocations and to engage
constructively in the efforts aiming at
reaching Solutions in a peaceful and
sustainable way always based on
international law
dear friends further to energy equation
of the Eastern Mediterranean one must
acknowledge that the common and pressing
challenges the region faces can be
addressed effectively only by acting
collectively
Cyprus is a pillar of stability and
Security in a volatile region actively
promotes its Regional cooperation policy
through the trilateral mechanisms of
cooperation is established with Greece
and other countries of the region in an
effort to create the regional synergies
and Partnerships
in Regional collaboration this Regional
collaborations have yielded tangible
results through the consolidation of
regional Partnerships that contribute to
strengthening our relations at the
political level as well as expanding and
deepening them in several actors such as
energy security and defense
Environmental Protection natural
disasters and cultural heritage
it goes without saying that no country
is excluded from such networks of
regional corporations provided that they
respect international law
further strengthening of our relations
with the countries of the Mediterranean
the Middle East North Africa and Gulf
will remain a key pillar of Cyprus
foreign policy
this empowers cybus to have an active
role as a geopolitical Gateway between
the European Union and the Mena region
we believe that Cyprus Regional policy
adds value to the European Union's
common foreign and security policy
our political ties with the countries of
the Southern neighborhood allow us to
bring strategic knowledge in the
relevant European Union discussions
while at the same time we are able to
convey key messages of their specific
concerns to our European Union partners
and vice versa
Cyprus geopolitical position and its
proximity to the continents of Asia and
Africa is another determining factor
most recently evident when the island
was utilized as a safe Transit Hub in
the evacuation efforts from Sudan
this was not the first time Cyprus has
assisted in such operations with the
most extended ones being during the
Lebanon crisis in 2006 when tens of
thousands were evacuated and provided
with humanitarian assistance proving the
lasting contribution of cyberus as a
reliable stakeholder and as a safe
harbor in the region
we shall continue to contribute our
Atmos whenever is needed
despite the challenges the region is
faced with we are also witnessing that
the Middle East and the Eastern
Mediterranean are on a positive
transformative trajectory
the changing political Dynamics around a
pause in our neighborhood such as the
recent approachment between Iran and
Saudi Arabia the Abraham Accords the
establishment of the East Mediterranean
gas Forum in Cairo and the maritime
border deal between Israel and Lebanon
constitute indicative examples of this
rapidly evolving geopolitical mosaic
The Wider Middle East and Gulf is not
just Cyprus neighborhood it is a
European Union's neighborhood and a
vital one at that
we need to acknowledge with courage and
honesty that as a European Union we have
not invested as much as we ought to in
this very important region
we we ought to boldly work on making it
a strategic priority to engage on a
positive agenda with our partners in the
region whom we must see as equal
Partners to assert a more active
extrovert role so as to effectively
reinforce the European Union ties with
the southern neighbors and in doing so
promoting peace and stability in the
region
foreign
dear friends turning to migration a
crisis that is linked also to this
important region we must take into
consideration the overall micro
migratory pressures that Europe is
facing with certain member States
including Cyprus being at the Forefront
in fact Cyprus is a member state with
the highest percentage of first-time
Asylum applications in relation to the
population
the military occupation of 37 percent of
the territory of Cyprus constitutes an
aggravating factor that hinders efforts
towards sound management flows since
control of those entering the country is
practically impossible
consequently Cyprus is particularly
vulnerable to the instrumentalization
practices used by their countries and
this is clear from statistical data
showing that over 90 percent of the
migrants applying for Asylum have
departed from Turkey
the government is committed to take all
necessary action to improve
infrastructure for the reception of
Asylum Seekers and expedite examination
procedures but also to increase the rate
of returns of those who do not have any
legal right to remain in Cyprus making
use of the support provided by the
European Union and its agencies which we
greatly appreciate
furthermore the government is in close
contact with the commission which is
preparing a dedicated action plan for
the Eastern Mediterranean microoratory
route
domestically we're also introducing a
bill next week for the establishment of
a deputy Ministry for immigration Asylum
and integration so as to better
coordinate and Implement our policies
which also of course include policies
for effectively integrating legally
residing Third Country Nationals however
it will be difficult to achieve tangible
and sustainable results in the absence
of addressing the root causes of the
phenomenal or in the absence of a
coordinated response at the European
Union level one that will convince
turkey to honor the obligations already
assumed towards all member states
last week the council rich and general
approach on two crucial aspects of the
new pact for migration and Asylum
the difficulty of the negotiations
demonstrates how complex the issue is
for all member states and how many
concessions has to be made in order to
reach this agreement
having said that I hope there are
discussions with the European Parliament
will proceed quickly
for the park to work it is imperative to
maintain balance between solidarity and
the principle of responsibility and to
keep working hard on the external
aspects of migration so as to reduce
irregular flows
dear friends an integral part of
promotion of Peace in the region of the
Eastern Mediterranean is our effort to
reunify Cyprus through a comprehensive
settlement in line with international
law U.N security Council resolutions and
the European Union law values and
principles
peace in Cyprus with the European Union
at the Forefront will send a resounding
message of Peace in a region that
desperately needs it
to everyone
the European Parliament
has always supported Cyprus and its
struggle to find a settlement to the
Cyprus problem a problem of invasion in
occupation which is still an open wound
in the whole of Europe
on behalf of the cypriot government and
on behalf of the cypriot people I'd like
to thank you for all your efforts and
for the key resolutions that are so
important for us including the
resolutions on famagusta of Russia and
the
approval and at some point increase of
their EU funding and donations in
relation to helping with missing persons
I'd like to thank the president of the
European Parliament for her genuine
personal interest and for all the work
done by the political groups to help end
the occupation and reunify our Island
the reunification of Cyprus through a
comprehensive comprehensive viable
settlement within the framework of what
has been agreed with the UN is the
number one priority of my government
49 years of occupation and division at
the heart of Europe are too many I can
assure you that I will spare no efforts
to
make sure that talks resume within the
framework of the of what has been agreed
on within the UN and on the basis of
that solution and where we left off at
Crown Montana in 2017. now in order to
achieve this I have met the Secretary
General and other officials of the UN
and EU institutions and my counterparts
and many EU member states and the
Turkish cypriot leader and in all my
meetings I have said that it is
absolutely necessary to take a new
approach and my proposal is to make sure
that the EU has an enhanced role both in
order to break the deadlock but also to
Breathe new life into the talks
I would like to take advantage of this
opportunity to make sure that this is
clear and there are no misunderstandings
we do not want to change the framework
for a solution which are always the
relevant resolutions of the UN General
Assembly after all they are our way of
protecting ourselves against the Turkish
approach of two states and let me also
say that we don't want the EU to replace
the United Nations on the country we
want the European Union to complement
the work done by the United Nations
we need to harness the EU as a tool that
brings about reunification because that
is the nature of the EU it is about
consensus it is about peace and about
respecting the human rights of everyone
this is what is enshrined in the
treaties of the European Union but also
the community are key
the Republic of Cyprus is an EU member
State and the Cyprus problem is a
European problem that requires European
Solutions it is in the interest of the
European Union but is also its duty to
actively contribute to uh settlement so
we can have a comprehensive settlement
and it needs to harness all the
political and economic means at its
disposal as well as the tools that it
has
even within the broader Euro Turkish
framework of Euro Turkish relations
I am I am very happy to discuss this
package within the framework of European
Turkish relations which will run in
parallel
with the negotiations on the agreed
basis
I would like to see a high-level
European principal politician become an
EU Envoy responsible for the Cyprus
problem I think that this would
contribute greatly it would help break
the deadlock and help
with the resumption of talks
of course if we all manage to get back
to the table then the European Union
will also have to provide technocratic
help like it did in the previous round
of negotiations
the presence of the European Union
contributed to a great extent to a lot
of convergence and that really helped
All cypriots Greek cypriots and Turkish
cypriots and the EU involvement was
decisive and it helped us
get very close to a settlement in back
in 2017 but at the moment the presence
of the EU is vital because we're really
looking at how we can break the
stalemates
the Cyprus problem can actually be a new
peace model for the EU it can
show that the EU has the necessary
toolkit and skills in order to help
bring about peace and security
this is our goal and we will work
tirelessly towards this aim and I hope
that everyone here in the European
Parliament will be our allies and
staunch supporters
ladies and gentlemen I would like to
conclude the speech today underscoring
the importance of the participation of
the Republic of Cyprus as a member State
on an equal footing I have emphasized
this in the past on numerous occasions
and I mentioned this today
um joining the EU is the biggest
historic achievement since the Republic
of Cyprus was set up 19 years after we
acceded to the EU I believe that despite
the difficulties and problems that our
European family has come up against I
believe that the participation of Cyprus
in the European Union is a strong
political Shield against any threats
that jeopardize our national security
the fact that the island of Cyprus is
still divided and it is still occupied
by turkey it constitutes the biggest
political anachronism at the moment and
yet we have a current Union of member
states the most modern in the whole of
the world
Jean Monet believed that problems could
be solved
by adding a new dimension to the issue
changing the initial framework of the
problem he said you change the context
you change the problem this is something
that he emphasized
I truly believe that if the EU is
becomes more involved in its
institutions become more involved and it
changes the framework of the problem and
if we can also put in the you're a
Turkish Dimension then I think that we
can break the deadlock and resume
negotiations and pick up where we left
up at back in July 2017 in order to come
up with a comprehensive settlement to
the Cyprus problem we don't want any
less or any more than what the citizens
of the rest of the EU member states have
the cypriot refugee the cypriot citizens
whether Greek cypriot or Turkish
separate whether Maronite Armenian or a
Latin has the right to enjoy the same
rights and his or her Homeland and has
to enjoy the same freedoms as any other
European citizen
this might seem obvious but this is our
goal and we truly believe that the
European Union can truly contribute to
this and become a catalyst for peace as
an independent candidate without the
support of any party
I was elected against the odds the first
time a President of Cyprus was elected
without the support of one of the two
big political parties
I know how to make brave bold moves
against the odds and I believe with
engagement from all parties and from the
European Union I can be the president to
solve the cyber's problem
I will wrap up by saying that for my
government
and personally I believe that a strong
EU means a strong Cyprus a strong Cyprus
means a stronger Europe
I'm politically committed to work
tirelessly in the European Council and
Beyond
in order to make sure that the European
Union Will Stand United
during this very difficult period that
we're going through with geopolitical
instability and the fact that war has
returned to our continent
I firmly believe that if we remain loyal
to the founding principles and values of
the European Union then we can hope for
better days we can hope for a better
stronger European Union that will only
benefit our citizens especially the new
generation of Europeans that are looking
at what we're doing every day and they
are crying out for Hope thank you very
much
thank you very much
president trustodolides
we now move to the speakers of the
different political groups starting with
the president of the Epp group for three
minutes
welcome in the European Parliament and
congratulations for your success for
your election as president for the
Mandate people of Cyprus gave to you
in 2004 your country fulfilled a long
time aspiration joining the European
Union
2008 you entered into the Eurozone
making your common market our Common
Market in our currency stronger
in 2012 Cyprus held its first presidency
over the European Council shaping the
European agenda from a recipient's point
of view
in the last 10 years Cyprus went from a
country on brink of collapse suffering
from mistakes of a former government
to European role model of prosperity and
stability you have regained your
country's Financial credibility after
the financial crisis through a
remarkable economic recovery with
discipline with hard work and is
responsible financial management and I
want to thank you also personally
because as foreign minister in the
cabinet of President anastasiadis you
also contributed to this success story
in 2026 you mentioned it already
you will hold again the presidency from
the European Council for the second time
we all hope it will be a presidency
without a bloody and ruthless War at our
doorstep
in Russian war in Ukraine has shaken the
whole Europe to its core and its rates
on Europe must continue to stand on the
side of ukrainians whatever it takes and
it is in these terrifying times it's
great to see cypriots next to the
ukrainians fighting for our European way
of life
a cypriot you know firsthand what it
means
to be attacked how it feels to live with
the open bound of a divided country an
open Bound for the whole of Europe
for us as Epp We Stand United behind
Cyprus our position on the Cyprus issue
has always been crystal clear clear
Cyprus issues are European issues there
can never be a United Europe with a
divided Cyprus
dear president in July 2024 will be the
50th anniversary of the Turkish
occupation of Cyprus no one in Europe
wants to celebrate this sad anniversary
we now have one year left
if it is time to find now a solution to
reunify Cyprus it's time
to finally heal this wound
now everyone is no longer in election
campaign perhaps this is also a chance
for more willingness to compromise
turkey must respect the sovereignty and
the territorial Integrity of Cyprus the
two-state solution proposed by the
Turkish side is unacceptable and its
military provocations in the offshore
drilling drillings in the territorial
borders of Cyprus
are violating international law erdogan
must stop playing Imperial games and
come to his senses
entity president
we must protect Europe from erdogan's
instrumentalization of migration on the
green line thank you for continuing the
hard work and taking important step to
regulate illegal migration you mentioned
it and to increase all the number of
returns of illegal migrants Europe does
not respond to erdogan's blackmailing
thank you turkey is an important partner
no doubt about this but we need now to
be clear in our talks with erdorm the
European Union must win back economic
strengths with Cyprus contribution led
us to everything possible so that soon
we can stop counting sad anniversaries
of occupation
and instead finally celebrating joyful
days of reunification thank you thank
you president Weber
next on behalf of the snd group I give
the flow to Costas mavarides for two
minutes
you might need again your headphones I
guess
Madam president
vice president
honorable president of the Republic of
Cyprus on behalf of the Socialists and
Democrats I would like to congratulate
you on your election and I'd like to
welcome you to the European Parliament
the European Parliament is the main
institution of the European family that
reflects the views of European citizens
the European Union faces key challenges
and objectives relating to the economy
Society the environment and security
but all of these are inextricably linked
and if we want to manage all of this we
need a European approach and uh
all-encompassing approach for example we
cannot achieve our environmental goals
our green economy goals uh and targets
relating to energy Society in other
areas if we don't manage migration
efficiently and if we also don't deal
with security so we support the efforts
to solve the Cyprus problem
caused by the Turkish Invasion and
continued occupation of cypriot
territory which is also EU territory as
you said yourself and rightly so I'd
like to say that the pandemic and the
Russian invasion of Ukraine highlighted
the potential of the European Union and
what we can achieve when we act in a
United fashion especially in the
European Council and I think this is
what we have to do when it comes to
Cyprus because Cyprus is the victim of
the violation of international law you
talked about the EU playing an active
role and you talked about the fact that
they need to contribute to the
resumption of talks so that we can have
a reunified European country on the
basis of the UN General Assembly
resolutions and the by and The Binding
rules and laws of the European Union
are a safeguarding guarantee for
prosperity in the future and would also
mean that all the legal citizens of
Cyprus are respected regardless of where
they come from their religion the
language they speak and so on
president here in the European
Parliament you have in the support of
all of us because I'd like to paraphrase
what the president of the European
Parliament said during her inauguration
speech the European Union cannot be
complete while we still have occupying
forces Turkish occupying forces and that
Cyprus is split we also understand that
there are a lot of problems in many
areas because the migration issue is
being exploited and the European Union
finally has made some steps I'm almost
done in the president just a few more
words as a political group we constantly
think of the European citizen
problem now young people women and other
vulnerable groups face certain problems
and the in tackling them are our
priorities we supported the resilience
and Recovery Fund and truly believe that
housing is important Interruption by the
president
if if you move towards a strategic
economy for a strong Europe and strong
Cyprus and for as long as you do that we
will stand by your side next the
president of the renew Europe group
stefanet for three minutes yeah
thank you madam president thank you for
specifying the allocated time Madam
president
sir I'd like to start sir by welcoming
you to the European Parliament
the people of Cyprus by electing you
have reaffirmed the European sentiment
but they also do not like it when the
status quo is imposed on them that is an
excellent sign of democratic Vitality
you know sir that my group is very keen
to see those who want to reform reform
and to are prepared to make changes you
have been unambiguously in support of
Ukraine as well as the support for the
Asylum and migration pack that is also
proof of your commitment in renew Europe
and as a part of our
political group as a part of your
majority
it is with respect then that we always
uh welcome those who have uh determined
that they would like to support those
who are pro-european and their role as
head of state of government moreover you
have supported the reunification of the
island yes Europe has a role to play too
frequently in Brussels we had the
feeling that this was a subject that
came down to Cyprus and Cyprus alone or
between Cyprus and turkey I think that
that is a mistake we believe that this
is a mistake 1.4 million fellow European
citizens live in a highly militarized
Zone
the conflict in Cyprus therefore impacts
us directly because the green zone is an
important
passage spot for illegal migration we
know precisely the path that is taken we
know also the challenge is that Greece
Italy Spain Malta face Cyprus as well
we cannot turn a blind eye to the
situation yes the issue of Cyprus is a
European question and we are prepared to
play our role in the resolution of
conflict we support your proposal of a
special Emissary we think that the
analysis is good and the
ball is also in the Turkish Court we
cannot accept a two-state solution the
conditions posed by President erdogan
just a few days ago are in violation of
international law Europe is a
guarantor of international law we have
shown
and along with Greece in the past we
must continue to do this along with us
Cyprus if need be that Cypress
sovereignty and European sovereignty are
uh
part and parcel of the European Union
and we will make sure that we support
you in the east of the Mediterranean you
can count on the renew Europe group
thank you again and thank you madam
president three minutes and 10 seconds
now I give the flow to the coacher of
the green group Philip lambes for two
and a half minutes
Mr President welcome uh to the European
Parliament I really appreciate these
opportunities that we have to debate on
the future of Europe with members of the
European Council because I'm one who
believes that Parliament and Council
have to work closely together that's the
only way to achieve success here
Cyprus enjoys uh a privilege actually
that actually no other member states has
and that is to have uh parts of its
territory militarily occupied that it's
not a privilege it's really a plague and
there I must commend your efforts and
your determination you deserve the
solidarity and the engagement of the
European Union to achieve a peaceful
reunification of the country and or
under international law we you have the
full support of the green CFA group in
order to achieve this there's a second
point where I do believe Cyprus needs
solidarity and the engagement of
European union and that's indeed an
asylum and migration yes countries such
as yours really carry uh more than
proportionate part of the effort of
welcoming people and indeed we cannot
let countries and the borders and
especially the southern borders of
Europe alone in that but Frankly
Speaking the Asylum and migration pact
that is currently being discussed in all
of you is not the kind of solidarity and
engagement that you need because yes
Manfred I agree that not everyone has
the right to live in Europe no we cannot
welcome the entire Humanity here but
Europe has also a responsibility towards
Asylum Seekers but also in the causes
that force people to migrate and there I
believe that Europe can do more we
cannot be just a fortress against the
rest of the world now there's two
aspects where I would like to see
engagement and solidarity from Cyprus
towards the rest of the European Union
the first is you know this music of
dirty money hovering around Cyprus these
golden passports granted to Guess Who
Russian oligarchs we need to root that
out no eu's citizen Citizenship is not
for sale and making friends with such
oligarchs well you you look what the
Russian regime is capable of uh I would
say Cyprus should know know better and
we fight against that kind of dirty
money finally
that's a green transition and yes I
heard you praising uh the opportunities
for the green transition but I also
heard you a lot speaking about oil and
gas and Frankly Speaking In 2023 oil and
gas cannot play a crucial role in the
transition we need really to embrace the
green transition not just as a necessity
but as an economic opportunity for all
of us thank you so we count on you for
that thank you Mr
Lambert's
now I get the floor tunic
of the ECR
thank you president colleagues in Cyprus
the past and the future of the European
Union come together
the story of this island is the the
story of the Mediterranean it's
geographical situation it's always
made it of great strategic value
since 2000 the UN have readable their
efforts to open a new cycle of
negotiation on the island and I feel
certain that the European Union must
strengthen its own hand in the
resumption of talks
that inevitably
in parallel to this lead us to defining
once and for all
the relations that we should have
between the European Union and turkey
while on the one hand
we can't accept any threat to cyprus's
sovereignty on the other hand
it's very much in all of our interests
to have a strategic partnership with
Ankara
for the purposes of Economic Development
and defense
yeah
took the the closing of
the the suspension of
turkey's membership musicians lead us to
constructive
relationship
your needs to Define its position
joining your
involves the bringing down of walls and
the bringing together of European
peoples we saw it in Berlin and in
Belfast
we need to make a success of this in
Nicosia 2. that's the last capital city
in Europe divided by a wall
but there's more to Cyprus than an area
where you see the
split between Europe and the Middle East
there are two key issues on our agenda
in its Waters too
look at the failure of Europe's policies
on Asylum and migration
fortunately something is changing
there's a new less ideological more
realistic approach
making Headway in the European Union
the significant gas deposits found in
Cyprus Waters held up near prospects the
developer of the Eastern Mediterranean
geopolitically as well as economically
in president
most of your problems
are similar to those faced by other
European member states particularly
countries such as Italy Spain Malta and
Greece
immigration
securing our borders energy the the
central role of the Mediterranean
fisheries and responsible tourism common
challenges
which
we need to tackle with a different
approach
than that which is applied up until now
in the current content context we are in
I'm an R2 we find ourselves opposing
certain proposals we disagree with but
as the European elections come along
following a range of recent national
elections we feel airless alone
the thinking behind arm proposals are
spreading far and wide
and very soon
we will be returning to Ithaca in and
out of the floor to the co-president of
the ID groups for two minutes
modern president of the European
Parliament
president of the public of Cyprus thank
you for joining us today in the chamber
of the European Parliament here in
Strasbourg
the whole question of national
sovereignty Independence and military
occupation have very good reason being
at the heart of our debate since
February 2022 Cyprus has been leading
such a struggle on a daily basis for
more than a quarter of a century we
often hear that the north of Cyprus is
occupied by turkey under the leadership
of president erdogan whose show no
willingness either to negotiate or to
and we work towards peace
the events yesterday regarding this
occupied part demonstrates his
unwillingness and the intractable
situation regarding the North Cyprus
Republic
as I've said many times in the past
turkey is one of the club of
international Powers which has been
trying to overturn the international
order
by threatening the sovereignty and
Maritime Waters of countries such like
some Greece
the policies conducted by President
Macco in France
involve a clear signal which Francis
sent out to the peoples of Greece and
Cyprus in the face of this unacceptable
intimidation
obviously it's very much in the interest
of our respective countries to continue
and needed to step up president our
cooperation when it comes to defense
a disciples issue
is not a purely local one
this is a europe-wide problem which
poses a real threat to our civilization
in the face of Turkey
if we recognize the threat from
erdogan's geopolitical Ambitions we can
see this clearly undermines our security
we should add to this immigration from
Africa which has been actively
encouraged by erdogan and this is a
challenge to the whole of Europe which
the rest of the European Union turns a
deaf ear to
president I would like to express the
hope that Europe finally stops turning a
blind eye by stating its clear support
for your country and your people you can
of course count on our support thank you
invite Mr Giorgio argue to take the
floor two minutes
thank you very much Madam president
president
I would like to welcome you here on
behalf of the group of the United left
welcome to Strasbourg we're going to be
stringent uh but fair with you as my
party akela usually acts and there's a
lot that we can say of course back in
Cyprus and I think that it's right that
you're asking for the more active
involvement of the EU by appointing a
high-level Representatives I can't see
much enthusiasm here in the chamber
maybe because they know things from the
past I don't know or maybe because they
their the accession process for turkey
has been put on the back burner and
moving and they're moving towards
something else but we're losing leverage
and Mr erdogan is only getting gifts a
Visa waiver Customs Union just so that
it doesn't take the side of Russia and
it can be a loyal NATO Ally and help us
with migration do you not think that the
time has come to harness the proposal
put forward by akel and to use energy to
harness energy as a catalyst for change
I would like to touch upon migration you
touched upon it as well I think that the
home affairs minister reached a deal
um
there's the issue of the EU turkey
agreement but there isn't a fair
distribution mechanism on the basis of
what each and every country can do so I
think the approach taken isn't uh is
immoral and Wealthy countries paid 20
000 per person and Southern countries
are becoming warehouses of human beings
I think president that Cyprus is in the
dock because of the illegal spyware
I welcome your commitment and the fact
that you said that you're doing
everything you can and that you're going
to take into account the committee's
issues now Mr Weber has left the chamber
but I'd like to say that uh Cyprus had
financial problems not because previous
governments made a change but because
the banking Union and the huge
capitalist crisis
I'm almost done president
um and that Mr Anastasia is inherited
meant that Cyprus ended up where it
ended up in but the war in Ukraine is
causing huge problems with expropriation
and I hope that you will respect the
directives and regulations of European
Union so that we can avoid a terrible
social tragedy that is in the offing
there are huge geopolitical and economic
difficulties with huge Interruption by
the president
president
if you are bold and courageous we will
stand by your side
for one minute
honorable president miss all the vice
presidents dambroskis president Christo
dolidas you mentioned in your speeches
the youth Logan United in diversity I
would like to ask you how do you
understand it I post this question
already during previous debates in the
future of Europe
does the word diversity only implied to
the borders and differences between
member states
whether these states remain themselves
as national state with only one official
language only one belief only one
appreciation of History
policy of linguistic genocide is taking
place
to my regret in many countries including
my country led by abolishing education
on minority languages more and more
political prisoners appears their only
guilt is difference opinion of recent
history I think very much or mention
only three names in Baltic states algres
palesque is in between
my country and Sergey denkins okay thank
you very much I need to give the floor
to the next speaker
next is Lucas for last for one and a
half minutes
Madam president president ladies and
gentlemen Cyprus is a small country and
the edge of Europe where the West meets
the east at a Crossroads of history and
culture and we have survived and are
surviving in this corner of the Earth
because we believe in the principles and
values that make us European Justice
solidarity and freedom
ladies and gentlemen Cyprus is the only
European country where part of its
territories under occupation it is
occupied by a country that has been
knocking on the door of Europe and that
wants to benefit politically and
economically but without offering
anything and without making concessions
a country with a government that doesn't
negotiate that doesn't sit around the
table and that keeps creating de facto
situations of the country we've got a
threat of war against countries of the
European Union we all know why because
apart from words our European Community
has never been has never wanted to put
pressure on turkey and take measures
that would make them back down and this
not only is not solidarity but also I
would even go as far as saying this is
about double standards and this policy
doesn't do it justice this practice is
unfair and it hurts us but despite that
we will fight hard because we believe in
Freedom even if we're alone we're going
to continue serving these principles and
values uh clamoring for our European
family to stand by our side President we
heard what you said but now it is Europe
that has to listen to you hear you and
Stand By Your Side you've asked for
action and a specific action that will
prove solidarity European solidarity
Isabel Santos for one minute
president
talking about the future a future of
reunification and Reconciliation also
implies looking to the Past
and
healing the wounds of the past
what about the 2000 cyprits
who disappeared
in 1973 in clashes and then in 1974 at
the time of the invasion all this time
has gone by and we still don't know what
became of
citizens of Cyprus
and
a large number of
turkiships as well
we can't
allow
divisionism to be perturbated because of
this
people
have been hard hit by the the loss of
members of the families without any
opportunity to mourn them
but the clock is ticking we need to
bring down barriers and build on the
work of the Disappeared people in Cyprus
committee to bring an end to this sorry
chapter I know you you are personally
committed to this and I hope you can
hold out some prospects of solving this
two minutes
[Applause]
thank you very much
president I in turn would also like to
welcome you to the European Parliament
on behalf of renew Europe
you are a politician who doesn't operate
within Party politics we have seen that
you are open to political cooperation
and independent individuals you've also
shown that you are a staunch proponent
of European unification and that you
want an enhanced role for the European
Union in striving for a settlement to
the Cyprus problem you have our support
but I would like to turn to all
colleagues and ask them to plug a huge
gap in the European strategy that could
be an obstacle over your efforts
President we have the Russian invasion
in Ukraine which is quite a crisis these
are the imperialistic
dreams of Putin we have the issue of
energy dependence on Russia and even
though the message were pretty clear in
with what happened in Georgia and than
in Crimea
in the Eastern Mediterranean we also
have other imperialist fantasies and
this is causing problems to the Republic
of Cyprus it's making it difficult for
them to harness their energy sources and
there are issues with migration and it
is uh jeopardizing its very future if
they now did the EU realize what was
happening does it still realize in this
uh does it realize what's going on they
didn't realize what was happening with
Putin in the past now erdogan and Putin
have a lot in common they've been in
power for a long time and they have
these imperialist fantasies as well now
it's extremely important for the EU to
stand by the side of the Republic of
Cyprus in real terms because otherwise
the EU will be taken aback once again by
things that shouldn't startle it
for one minute
thank you
and thank you for your visit present
this Union is a union of equals but
yours yours is a special case for
decades your country has been in the
epicenter of so many challenges some
imposed from outside others
self-inflicted fossil Explorations
golden visas implementation of sanctions
against Russia and holding against
foreign threats
um this may due to the epicenter of
history and this history made you to
what you are an island of geopolitical
pitfalls and geopolitical aspirations as
chair of the delegation of the European
Union uh to EU turkey joined
parliamentary committee I salute your
humanitarian efforts in the wake of the
terrible earthquake in Turkey I strongly
believe that Cyprus conflict can be
overcome and I commend your personal
dedication to break the deadlock with
the help of your allies our solidarity
to the Republic of Cyprus is and will
remain unbroken and this must be made
clear to all the regional Powers dear
president let us work together for a
sustainable peaceful and Progressive
Cyprus thank you
[Applause]
to come
thank you
it means so many different things to so
many people for me it was and it still
is a dream a promise of freedom and
equality between women and men a promise
of freedom
to think and express your opinions
without hearing for your life a promise
of having your voice heard on the global
scene a promise of Peace Europe
This Promise is showing more and more
cracks because we forget to be its
Guardians and we take it too often for
granted these cracks are more and more
visible also to others
what shakes our Europe at its core and
make us often Shiva is both a
combination of threats from the inside
and from the outside outside we have of
course China and Russia daring us we
have all seen how turkey is continuously
deceiving us and acting like a throwing
horse inside International organizations
accumulating provocations in the
Mediterranean Sea sabotaging unity in
your country using our failure to
address address the migration policy as
an instrument against us
look inside as well from the inside we
fail to keep order and be strong enough
to be taken seriously look at the
institutionalization of victimhood that
became very fashionable and how we get
used to council culture instead of
choosing Excellence this was not how
Europe was built to keep its promise
Europe must do one very simple thing do
its job and honor its history thank you
has the floor
thank you very much president the
president ladies and gentlemen I'm very
happy to be able to continue this debate
this is Europe
when the illegal migration continues
as it has continued so 2015 then this
this is Africa is going to it's not
going to be this is Europe anymore
there are seven million people who've
arrived since 2015 since the Arab Spring
most of them
okay
did not was not been given the status of
a Geneva Convention Refugee after
examination of their case most of them
are not under International protection
rather these people have arrived with
hope
and they have disregarded all the rules
and so those people who are here
illegally
they
that means 80 percent of them have been
encouraged to return home but they have
not done so so in this migration stream
there's been a cultural transformation
in large European Metropolis if you go
Munich Brussels Paris or Vienna where I
come from it's not just a cultural
transformation but you can also deny
this serious security issues and safety
issues if we talk about all the attack
on the Brussels Airport what would
happen yesterday in France with the
knife attack so ladies and gentlemen I
will conclude now Europe cannot have a
future if we do not address illegal
migration and say to people that we are
prepared to help them back at home but
not let them into Europe thank you
next speaker
is Mr kisirak
thank you Mr chair
brother
president welcome
first of all allow me to wish you the
best of success in your new duties
our country Cyprus
it has been through great trouble since
1964 and we have a de facto split since
1974.
I would like to express my support to
you for every step that you will take
towards a settlement of the Cyprus
problem on the basis of a by zono by
communal Federation with political Unity
of both communities there's no other
realistic solution and the other
Solutions are unacceptable and denying
political Unity actually political
equality of Turkish cypriots is
unacceptable as well peace in our
country will be based on bringing both
communities closer together in the same
way as the European peoples are managed
to come out of conflict it's also
extremely important to make sure that
the turkey Cyprus come closer to the EU
I call upon the Republic of Cyprus to
step up its efforts to strengthen
relations between the Turkish Cyprus and
the European Union president I'm
speaking Greek to you because Turkish my
mother tongue is an official language of
the Republic of Cyprus but it is not
included in the official languages of
the European Union I call upon you to
put an end to this unfairness my party
aquel put forward a set of proposals on
Turkish cypriots such as including them
in Erasmus mixed marriages and so on I
hope that you will Factor all of this in
take this on board and proceed with your
work along these lines thank you
Mr Nick Mr Bay Michelle presidents
50 years ago turkey invaded Cyprus
look Congress by brute force was
followed by the more lasting conquest of
democracy Ankara has sent tens of
thousands of Turks to populate the
northern half of the island
overseen by a puppet government that no
one recognizes that doesn't prevent
Sultan erdogan constantly provoking his
constantly calling for the partition of
Cyprus into two countries the same
erdogan who's carrying out illegal
Drilling in Cyprus
um territorial Waters and violating
Greek airspace
he was re-elected a fortnight ago he's
close to the Muslim Brotherhood he's
re-islamized his population and is
supporting his limits on our soil he
converted zensifier into a mosque and
he's inciting Tux in Europe to have five
children I'm quoting this to speed up
the great replacement on our continent
he's the same man
who's extorting tens of millions of
euros while pushing hundreds of
thousands of magnets towards our borders
and the Greek Islands for all these
reasons he's the threats and insult the
suffering of your people and the theft
of your land that time has come as
present to bring a definitive end to
turkey's accession process of the
European Union thank you thank you
Thank You Cher
Mr President
commissioner
I have to congratulate you on your
recent election
and especially in your commitment and
engagement with European values and
European Union
we have today a Maltese president of the
European Parliament welcoming the
President of Cyprus in this house and
this means that in Europe there is no
periphery
Mr President I want to be very clear
we stand for reunification of Cyprus we
condemn the illegal occupation of North
territory in Cyprus
indeed with the illegal and brutal
Russian invasion and occupation of
Ukraine I believe that today European
union and European peoples are in a
better condition to understand the
impasses in which Cyprus finds itself
we cannot have double standard and so I
would like to ask you how do you
evaluate the European Union's commitment
to the question of Cyprus in the recent
years
and what is the exact model that you are
proposing when you are asking for the
European Union active role that would be
my questions because we believe that the
peaceful prosperous reunified Cyprus
will always be in the Easter interest of
a peaceful and purpose European Union
you can count on us thank you very much
thank you
our next speaker is Mr kohut to
flossions
foreign
Union has written its history
the European Union funds the purchase of
arms for Ukraine
placing sanctions on Russia's essential
we should step up our efforts
That's essential for our community and
for our countries
we have to ensure that our
decision-making mechanisms be made more
efficient so as to enable us to
intervene more quickly
the time has come to bring an end to the
veto for foreign policy we have to bring
an end to National egoism which is a
threat to our security we have to bring
an end to free votes
which led to the collapse of Poland in
the 19th century we have to bring an end
to Auburn his cronies and other
populists president the shadow
rapporteur on the report
calling for inclusion of Cyprus in the
Schengen information system
I've done my best in trying to ensure
that country can play a full role in the
European Union
in this function I have fond memories of
our past cooperation and I know we can
fully count on your leadership for a
Sovereign and Democratic Union you
mentioned your speech Germany and the
change of context I do believe that the
Ukrainian conflict has a change of has
changed the context and that the
enlargement has become a fundamental
geopolitical tool and geopolitical
question against this background
I think that it is not credible to go to
to what the next enlargement without a
deep reform of the European Union of the
institution of the common policies and
that we must address their resolved
territorial issues within the Union in
particular in view of the next
enlargement again this background again
and in view of the Cyprus presence in
2026 I would like to better understand
from you what are your key priorities
for the reform of the European Union and
what do you expect the union to do more
or differently with regard to the Cyber
territorial issues to break the deadlock
thank you very much
Mrs Henrico Hein you have the floor
Tim is the president Cyprus is an
important member state of the European
Union and Europe is interested in a
stable peaceful situation in the Eastern
Mediterranean and southern Europe
Turkish military Sable rattling will not
change that
Cyprus has an important role in
achieving the EU climate and
environmental goals and we need the best
possible European cooperation in that
especially on renewable energies and not
necessarily on fossil fuels of course
and we welcome the current progress on
structural reforms of the justice system
in Cyprus pointing to the commission's
2022 rule of law report including the
necessity of better investigating
high-level corruption cases and for us
in the European Union it's also very
important that sanctions against Russia
are properly enforced you're looking for
the forwards to the cooperation and
that's for sure Europe needs Cyprus as
much as Cyprus nissira thank you
thank you thank you very much the next
speaker is Mr visterson
president president
year after year we continue president
year after year we continue to tell Sam
to Q continue to see this farce of
turkey as an EU candidate country and
then we see the election of adwan again
the same turkey the year and year uh
bribe and extort Europe to give us
millions and millions of
taxpayers money and it's turkey who
keeps your country uh occupied in
military occupation for decades so how
long is this farce going to continue how
long are we going to pretend that turkey
somehow belongs in the EU in Europe how
are we long are we going to keep writing
a blank check to the islamist arrogant
and his regime in Ankara we have to end
this this has has to stop we have to end
the candidate status of Turkey
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker
is not currently present so I will give
the floor to Mrs Vincy
thank you
president
for decades now Cyprus has faced
overwhelming challenges
this is perhaps one of the reasons that
Cyprus was also able to recover quickly
from the economic impact of the pandemic
pandemic
however lots of other countries Cyprus
is obliged to quickly reduce its
dependence on Russia and particular it
comes to Services it's taking great
steps in this direction by focusing on
digitization and high level research
president
you referred to gas reserves which
hopefully will make a contribution to
ensuring that the European Union can
produce its dependence on Russia when it
comes to gas and oil thereby supporting
your process transformation you're
ambitious forward-looking policies
also show how you intend to use General
money from Next Generation EU to help
strengthen the European energy
networks and
reinforced sustainable energy that's
very important obviously migration is an
essential question for you
like
Austria Cyprus failed to get
satisfactory answers from the European
Union regarding efforts to stem enormous
flows of migration talks are underway in
the council but it's very important now
for the whole of Europe that we quickly
step to implementation of the measures
adopted
president I wish you all the best when
it comes to rolling out your plans
and in particular to in your in efforts
to ensure that Cyprus continue to play a
full role in the European Union a minute
thank you welcome president
we're living through difficult
extraordinary times the pandemic the
Russian invasion of Ukraine the global
climate crisis have all taught us that
it's only if we're United that we can
provide our continent with the future
together we have done and are doing so
much I have in mind Next Generation EU
the covid vaccines measures for the
green and digital transition and our
first steps towards the European Defense
Union and yet Europe is often seen by
our citizens as something remote or
maybe even hostile
The Winds of nationalism and division
that we see today
pose a risk of turning the the clock
back in historical terms
in a year's time we'll be holding
European elections it's up to us to
provide some substance which will
provide hope for our citizens again
starting with young people holding out
plus bits rather than talking about
fears colleagues and peasant we have to
lay the missing part of the foundations
of Europe a social European solidarity
ever more united a shared home where
each and every one of us
can be players and think and speak
European okay for one minute
thank you very much president
commissioner honorable president of the
Republic of Cyprus the act of
involvement of the European Union uh in
order to help solve the Cyprus problem
is key but it's also vital for the EU to
play its historic role as an
international player because we cannot
have a member state where the community
are key suspended and part of the
country and we can have a candidate
country Turkey having occupying troops
on European soil but allow me to mention
two factors that are linked to the
European involvement of Cyprus first of
all harnessing of energy and natural gas
there must not be any further delays and
there has to be European investment
Cyprus a member state has a very
important opportunity to contribute to
the Strategic autonomy of the EU the
second factor is the time Factor time is
working against us when it comes to
harnessing guest deposits if we don't
move forward over the next five years
then it will no longer be that appealing
even in Europe with high Technologies
and low costs we have 40 percent of the
energy mix made up of renewable energy
sources over the next four years during
your term it's important for Cyprus to
turn towards the future for one minute
Europe German
and the European story of Cyprus shows
that everything is possible that the EU
makes it possible for a country to live
in peace and overcome the most difficult
moments in history you're a model for
the future accession of Moldova to the
EU if Cyprus managed to overcome its
internal barriers and divisions then the
European integration of Moldova will not
be prevented by the pet interests of the
transnistrian authorities I take this
opportunity to urge you to make
available the pre-accession funds for
Moldova and speed up its accession
I come from a country that ensures the
protection of the external borders of
the European Union I can very well
understand the challenges faced by
Cyprus and I can urge you to adopt a
common position that would bring real
solutions and stability in the region we
have to reunite Europe around our
democratic values and around mutual
respect and must understand that the
important items on the agenda of every
state must be of interest for the entire
Union for one minute
foreign
of the Republic of Cyprus I in turn
would like to welcome you to the
European Parliament
president we're going through a very
difficult period we need to remain
level-headed and make sure that we don't
have de facto situations and post on us
and we don't get the kind of rhetoric
that we heard from Mr erdogan yesterday
however I would like you to say a few
words about issues that don't pertain to
Cyprus problem gender equality which is
one of the
fundamental values of the European Union
as the only female
cypriot MEP I feel a huge sense of
responsibility for us to solve this what
is your vision for Cyprus in the Europe
of the future when it comes to gender
equality how can we effectively tackle
this problem how can we do so decisively
so we can help Every Woman every young
girl who is listening to us and who
wants a future without discrimination
the Methodist papadak is for two minutes
foreign
the cypriot people entrusted you with
their votes and they want substantial
change golden passports Pegasus Panama
papers these are events which
unfortunately have tarnished the image
of our country and have meant that our
society feel disillusioned with
political life we want a catharsis in
cypriot society we want to be able to
restore our
pride and image we want a modern rule of
law in Cyprus a free Homeland on the
basis of the Europe barometer Paul most
Cyprus feel that what the EU does has a
direct impact on their daily lives and
they say that
at some points in time or almost or even
all the time it's difficult for them to
make ends meet and to pay the bills and
they're not happy with the measures
taken by the government or the European
Union the future of Cyprus is
inextricably linked to the future of
Europe and the European Parliament is uh
fighting for a better Europe and we
expect the same from you there's a whole
issue of energy so that we can have a
strong and Democratic Cyprus that will
also help with a better Europe separate
citizens uh deserve decent wages they
are clamoring for a state that will
provide decent housing to everyone and
that will support young people that will
invest in new technologies and that will
promote entrepreneurship they want
support for the most vulnerable groups
they want a clean
environment by implementing the green
deal in a country will be able to
harness solar power and all its benefits
and we can also aim for sustainable
development uh now for 49 years Cyprus
has been under Turkish occupation we are
striving for European solution and it is
right that we want more active
involvement of the EU to help us achieve
a settlement President we recognize the
fact that you have clear will we know
that you want to do this and we expect
action you and now dear president
Christo the leaders after this very
wide-ranging and comprehensive exchange
of use can I ask you please to take the
podium again to respond this full
chamber
foreign
president honorable members of the
European Parliament commissioner
I have been greatly encouraged by what I
heard here today thank you very much for
your support
thank you very much for supporting our
initiative to have the EU more actively
involved in the efforts to solve the
Cyprus problem
the message that I hear loud and clear
is a universal support
and I hope that in the future the
conditions will be there so that with
the active participation of the EU we
will achieve our goal to resume talks
and solve the Cyprus problem I would
like to mention that I am thrilled with
the fact that you understand the huge
challenges that Cyprus faces not just
Cyprus but also other countries when it
comes to migration the European Union
cannot afford the luxury of failing we
have to work together
we have to tackle this together and
we'll only be able to solve this problem
if we also tackle the root causes
underpinning migration
the time cause rain let me very briefly
very very briefly touch on on some
issues raised by by the interventions
first of all on climate and and
on the issue of climate we we view the
environment as a valuable headaches that
needs to be protected my reference to
oil and gas is because of the role that
oil and gas can play as a bridge
to reach the European green deal that is
why I I I stress the importance of of
oil and gas I want to mention something
on the issue of missing persons
sincerely we appreciate the parliament's
continual interest in in this
humanitarian issue is demonstrated also
by there is an appointment of a new
Special Report there the issue of
missing persons constitutes one of the
most tragic aspects of the Turkish
Innovation and continuing occupation of
my country the families of the missing
persons say the Greek Cyprus or Turkish
cypriots are entitled to recover the
remains and their of their loved ones
and know the circumstances under which
they they went missing
uh
Now by way of conclusion president
ladies and gentlemen I'd like to
underscore the historic debts that we
have
and I am addressing you here in the
house of European democracy I believe
that we have a historic duty to work
together
so that this project based on peace and
prosperity and our European family the
Legacy that was bequeathed upon us can
also bequeathed by us to the new
generations and that it will be stronger
and more resilient I truly believe that
we can achieve this
and what I can say today with certainty
is that as the elected representative of
the cypriot people I will do everything
I can as a member of the European
Council in order to promote further
integration of the European Union I am a
staunch proponent
of European integration and I will do
everything I can on my part to have this
institutional deepening with more common
policies and do everything we can so
that the EU can really be a key player
on the international stage my vision of
the EU also is also based on a reunified
Cyprus I know we cannot change geography
I know that we cannot choose our
neighbors or change our neighbors and I
fool well what difficulties lie within
the Cyprus problem but at the same time
my vision for a stronger Europe is based
on a reunified and strong Cyprus that
will be an even more active role in the
European Union and that is why I would
like to wrap up my speech by making the
most of the fact that I'm here in the
European Parliament and I would like to
send a message to our Turkish Cyprus
countrymen and we women they are
citizens of the Republic of Cyprus and
they are citizens of the EU and their
future the future of the Armenians
maronites and Latins and the all
separate people
is
based on the fact that we are a member
state of the European Union
and as president of all cypriots my uh
greatest achievement and Legacy will be
to bequeath to our children a reunited
Cyprus a reunified country that will be
an even stronger partner in a stronger
European Union thank you very much
thank you very much president Christo
the leades for this exchange and I now
suspend the session for a couple of
minutes before the vote takes place
thank you